l'année dernière j'avais dit que
franchement qu'elle y était la
révélation de l'année pour moi cette
année je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
avec franchement raymond qui a explosé
cette année on va pas se mentir qui a
été exceptionnel qui est devenu
indispensable à l'émission je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez mais c'est vrai
que a motivé la question cette année
pour vous quel est le chroniqueur il ya
le plus marqué l'année et je le dis
franchement pour moi j'ai dit allez nana
je crois que c'est kelly qui est
vraiment qui a émergé et cette année
pour moi je dis je dis la vérité pour
moi c'est l'année de raymond qui a été
exceptionnel m obligé de dire le même
producteur comment il pour moi vraiment
raymond a été exceptionnel cette année
les ide a amené un vrai truc qu'on
n'avait pas dans l'émission et je suis
très très fier de lui parce que c'est
mon pote est vraiment non vraiment je
suis fier de lui mais combien de fois
après les émissions je me disais raymond
c'est quand même énorme c'est un énorme
talent et que et ça m'a fait plaisir
aussi de ne pas me tromper mais valérie
pour tasser sait qui c'est serré
monsempron je parle beaucoup avec
raymond s'envoie des petits mots des sms
et je pense que c'est vraiment cette
année parce que vraiment au tout début
j'avais peur moi pour lui qu'ils soient
enfermés dans un personnage
le type qui va qui va travailler entre
guillemets dans la vraie vie comme si
nous nous étions dans une autre vie et
qui râlent tout le temps et en fait il
sait il a déployé ses ailes
il a osé dire des choses il a osé être
heureux aussi il a osé s'amuser oseo s'y
est pas simplement le type qui
revendique tout le temps et etc il s'est
complètement intégré et qu'elle est très
drôle et surtout raymond il a une
qualité extraordinaire c'est qu'à chaque
fin d'émission
qu'on soit d'accord pas d'accord on se
parle et on est en avance ensemble et on
dialogue ensemble et on voit là et ça
s'est jamais pour le chroniqueur de la
saison dit la vérité
on a une vraie relation c'est vrai que
deux trois fois ils étaient pas n'était
pas bien et je lui dis coup devient la
maison bien voir à quoi les maisons il a
débarqué à 23h30
d23 faut il est monté dans les tours je
lui rends calme et j'ai fait un peu le
grand frère avec lui et c'est vrai qu'il
est il est bon parce que lui il bat de
la télé comme les gens qui la regarde
non pas comme ceux qui la font et
l'huile c'est un mec bien ça mec en or
et c'est vrai que moi je suis très
proche de lui et je serai toujours là
pour lui hormis ces tout chroniqueur de
l'année pour toi pour moi ça restera
mathieu surville occupent l'espace voilà
c'est un showman effet l'impact acquis
mais raymond c'est moi j'adore ma folie
ouais mais pour moi c'est un message
elle assure mathieu on le sait bon je
répondrais break
j'ai découvert ça l'est un peu plus
parce que lui non mais vous c'est
matures c'est mathieu meilleurs éléments
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on termine
émission en revanche là où on continue à
son bruit sur projet lui dire de rentrer
chez lui je déconne mais non il est
toujours afrique star donc sa sincérité
pour se chauffer pour qu'ils s'équipent
où le produit est bon il n'entre c'est
vraiment qu'on apporte la ligue le mans
l2 et alger parce que je dirais mon nom
mais il est surprenant parce que alors
c'est un type qui est très intelligent
mais c'est normal je ne connaissais pas
et tu as toujours un argumentaire
extrêmement juste qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas d'accord ce que tu dis à chaque fois
est très frappant très justifiées très
appuyé etc tu donne toujours des
exemples va partir kelis et qui pourtant
le chroniqueur de la vie non moi c'est
moi mais bon bah moi ce n'est pas un
secret - il le sait bah c'est raymond
pour le coup moi c'est pas moi qui lui
apporte quelque chose mais c'est lui qui
m'apporte quelque chose pour moi c'est
mon grand frère il le sait et on se le
dit souvent
et est ce qui est rigolo avec raymond
c'est que on se rend pas compte de
l'humour qui la basse et surtout en fait
il a un il est tellement drôle défunt je
ne dors pas assez un plateau parce qu'il
a vraiment un humour des deux jours qui
le montrent encore plus
mais voilà les sacs est ce qu a dit
jean-louis tout à l'heure c'est que
raymond
ils commencent les débats avant
l'émission il l'est continue pendant et
après c'est le dernier à partir après
tout le monde la factory semé enfin les
locaux ferme remo il est encore là à
parler avec tout le monde et a parlé de
démissionner et c'est vraiment c'est
vrai là c'est vrai qu'il ya un humour
d'où il a demandé ou flammes etc qui
prend la tête je touche qui devait
relier je suis en tête maxime très
clairement raymond fait partie c'est
vrai et on s'est taillé un franc parler
mais il ya un sens à présent qui pour
vous alors il y répond dans le top 3
même pour moi c'est qu'il y ait appris
qui acquit une assurance
encore là si la terre je pense qu'il ya
rien derrière ils le pensent khalil al
hayya nuit alors taquine assurances sur
tous les sujets même sujet un peu
complexe qui sortent de l'univers
médiatique
tu as aussi un franc parler tu as du
caractère tu sais le montrer à l'antenne
et c'est ça que j'aime hatem ben arfa
est pour toi le chroniqueur de l'année
alors évidemment c'est raymond
franchement c'est vraiment c'est pas les
servir la soupe et mais j'ose dire que
tu as raison pour kelly alors kelly elle
a pris une assurance incroyable cette
année parce que ferait manger à l'année
dernière
elle balance non mais déjà pu le dire
non quand en plus c'est être suis je
trop d'ailleurs les derniers mois encore
un peu plus mais raymond ce qu'il a de
tout champ vraiment est intéressant
c'est que d'abord il est vrai il y
triche pas il est très entier il est
vrai que nous on est quand même rompu à
l'exercice de la télévision depuis des
années donc notre à beinheim ans est un
peu différente
à l'inversé mathieu alors séparément
pour moi j'ai juste dire un mot sur
raymond sincèrement parce que ça qu'on
s'est parfois pris la tête parfois ça
continue dans les vestiaires et comme il
est aussi véhément que moi c'était un
connard non c'est toi mais deux heures
après c'est fini comme souvent les gens
qui m'ont tué ce qui est de ce qui est
excessif est insignifiant donc je t'aime
beaucoup raymond après pour être très
honnête et voilà je le dis honnêtement
mais je pense qu'en revanche celui qui
est le plus complet qui est plus drôle
qui fait le plus de show est vraiment
sans lui un manque
je pense que c'est moi mais je suis
honnête je vois là je suis sûr que tu
adores
jean michel germa deal pour l'appliquer
pour vous le chroniqueur alors moi pour
le plan table moi j'ai eu la chance de
faire toute la saison à côté de raymond
et c'est vrai que c'est une association
un peu comme ça a priori un peu bizarre
et ça a été ça a été vraiment génial
parce que finalement on pense jamais
pareil mais on pense tout le temps
pareil
est ce que j'aime avec raymond c qui
montent comme du lait mais il est temps
comme du beurre et jamais c'est vrai
parce qu'il est souple et il est
travaillé pour les produits diététiques
donc ça vraiment j'ai voilà alors il a
fait évidemment une année absolument
excellente mais moi j'ai une tendresse
particulière pour jean michel
ce que je trouve qu'il a tout le temps
quand même une sorte de d'autodérision
d'humour d'argumentaire isla gel il a
des arguments que trouve excellent et je
trouve je me jolin marche très très bien
là la brochette kelly gens me chauffe
que c'est un truc est assez explosif et
moi qui m'a plu parce que je suis en
face d'eux je trouve que ça fonctionne
très bien et qui a déjà vu jean michel
de mauvaise humeur dont une émission
chat maintenant il est d'humeur égale
tout le temps j'ai quand tu fous rien de
journée une tenue à mes yeux c'est vrai
qu'il a raison grave aujourd'hui on va
pas se plaindre en tout cas merci
réagissez sur les réseaux sociaux dit
nous pour vous qui est le chroniqueur de
l'année remo ce qui pour toi tu as
d'ailleurs à moi mal en moi je vais pas
dire tout le monde valérie dans les
débats benjamin dans la dans la dans la
rage kelly la révélation pour moi aussi
j'en mis la franchise qui parce qu'il
triche pas il sait qu'il va se faire
défoncer mais disent qu'ils pensent et
géraldine tous à tout le monde mais ça
reste quand même lui mais avec et les
chants et m'énerve
ils vont insupportable mais quand il est
là quand même
il ya un rytme il est bon je vais vous
dire la vérité dit ce qu'il pense il dit
je prends des risques et et je les aime
bien ce connard moi je vais vous dire la
vérité pour moi et je vous dis je vous
tous je trouve tous très bon tennis je
trouve qu'elle a fait je voulais dit
déjà l'année dernière c'était la
révélation johnny depuis les années
mathieu on sait qu'on a des talents
raymond pour moi c'est la révélation
géraldine voilà tous les autres voilà
benjamin c'est bon c'est mon frère est
heureusement qu'il est là pour constater
des dards cas pendant les pubs aussi
maxime maxime jeu l'adorent humainement
et même dans l'émission il a un vrai il
a un vrai truc bernard c'est aussi la
deuxième révélation de l'année pour moi
car
car tenez sur les nerfs mais pour moi et
je vous le dis et je le dis la vérité
pour moi la numéro 2 de l'émission ces
terres là un bis et je le dis et moi
quand elle n'est pas là je sens vraiment
un très grand vide dans l'émission et
c'est pour ça que c'est je le dis c'est
la seule qui a joué tout le temps avec
moi c'est valérie c'est vrai il s'est
vraiment mal parce que valérie que ce
soit dans les débats dans l'humeur dans
le rythme dans la musique quand est-ce
que j'ai besoin du rire de valérie dans
les relances pour moi voilà je vous dis
la vérité
valérie on voit qu'elle a beaucoup
beaucoup de métier et pour moi c'est ma
1 bis et je le dis la vérité et c'est
non mais franchement je dis la vérité
shenzhen chine a un tout petit truc ce
qui a dû souvent elle prend la parole en
premier
quand un plan c vrai débat c'est très
dur de prendre la parole en premier bon
après ça tourne il ya les arguments on
peut jouer les uns et les autres on peut
dire bah lui je réagis sur ce qu'il a
dit oui elle à la personne pour réagir
et le pardon est vraiment valérie n'est
pas là et je sais vous êtes tous
importants mais je vous jure que la
première personne que je couche sur la
feuille
c'est valérie parce que valérie c'est
vrai c'est vraiment vraiment c'est la
numéro on ait ses limites voilà que ces
vagues à hawaï à valérie kaki à côté de
moi à les limites wallace et c'est une
co animation quoi plus mascarade je
dirais été parce que c'est vrai que vous
n'en parlez pas beaucoup de valérie
souvent parce que valérie elle est
tellement mine de rien vous avez
tellement l'habitude de la voir avec na
qu on oublie un travail qu'elle fait et
l'importance qu'elle a raison c'est
quand elle n'est pas là qu'on se rend
compte que vraiment c'est vraiment très
compliqué ce qui se passe quand elle
avait été absente à cause de ce break je
me souviens moi je vous chie mais à ce
moment là ils savent et le disent très
compliqué week est désemparé par rapport
au plan de table
heureusement isabelle a pris le relais
physiquement et on oublie zabel qui
formidable isabelle franchement je vous
dirais je dis la vérité isabelle s'en
prend plein tout le monde là ils
tremblent un fan et tout le temps elle
entend pas il est toujours de bonne
humeur
alice et un amour est toujours contente
d'être là je suis désolé franchement
c'est quand même quelqu'un savait pas et
vous ne la fera pas venir j'ai été
préféré elles changent jamais pour la
part des rigolades al-shihri
et mon art est autorisée mais le
personnel derrière moratoire merci